عملت قشاطه سطل وصرت ابره مع المحلات انا
بقول لهم انا بنظف بيوت بشتغل بالتنظيف
مين فيه يشغلني عندي ايدين وعندي قشرين
استفيدوا من خدماتي
[موسيقى]
انا خضر احمد مزوج وعندي ولدين بشتغل
مساعد منزلي بخدم بالبيوت وبنظف البيوت
انا كنت اعتني بمسمنين كنت اهتم بمسنين
اخر مسن بقيت عنده تقريبا شي ثلاث سنين من
بعد هيدي صار في ازمه توفى المسن وانا
فصرت فتش على شغل شفت كتير ناس عم بتسافر
بالبحر شفت كتير ناسها حاولت فكرت بالهجره
انا لا انا قلت لا يا خضر اتفضل انت شوف
قرر اختار شيء طريقك
[موسيقى]
انا علمت اولادي وفهمتهم وخبرتهم انه انا
بروح بشتغل بالمنازل وهيدا الشغل عم
بشتغلوا كرمال اعلمكم يا بابا وتصيروا شي
بالمجتمع حلو واي حدا بحاول انه يتعرض لكم
قولوا له انه نحن بندعي له للبابا كل يوم
الله يرزقك وعد الله يحميك وانا دعوه اهلي
ودعوه اولادي بتكفيني هلا
اعلمهم وخبرت الكل مثل ما انتم عم بتعلموا
اولادكم بمدارس خاصه انتم مش احسن مني انا
بدي اعلم اولادي العلم مدارس خاصه وعم
علمهم لحتى يكبروا ويصيروا شي بالمجتمع
بالنسبه لاصحابي انا خسرت كتير اصحابي
لانه هن بيعتبروا انه هذا الشغل للنسوان
ابدا هذا الشغل مش لون النسوان في كتير
ناس صارت تكتب لي على السوشيال ميديا انه
هذا الشغل للمراه يقولوا لي انت مثل
النسوان انت مثل المراه ابدا في ناس
بالشارع بزقوا علي اصحاب خسرتهم
مجتمع هون كبيئه نحن مجتمعاتنا ما بتتقبل
هيك شغل ورغم كل هذا انا لحتى استر عائلتي
واعتبرت انه هيدي الشغله هيدي شغله مهنه
اعتبرتها انه هيدي مهنه
في ناس بتكتبلي بخصرك يا حلوه
شو اليوم وين شغلك يا يا مراه
انت ست الستات ليش ليش عم بتصنفوا الانثى
كانه هي خدامه ابدا طول ما انت عم تشتغل
بكرامتك وبعرق جبينك اشتغل وارفع راسك
عم بشتغل كل يوم بيومه عندي ادويه عندي
اجار بيت انا عايش مع اهلي امي وابي ومرتي
وولدين مستاجر بيت وطبعا اجورات كتير ناس
بتعرف قديش ارتفعت نهار يلي بشتغل بناكل
وبنسرق وبنقدر ندفع يوم ما بنشتغل بدنا
نبين
كان عندي حلم لما كنت صغير وهذا الحلم ان
شاء الله بتمنى انه يتحقق انا كان عندي
هوايه هو التمثيل كان عندي هوايه احب الفن
احب مجال السوشيال ميديا فلما لقيت حالي
انه لا انه انا ماني عم بقدر اوصل لمجال
التمثيل او لمجال التلفزيونات حاولت تدخل
الفرحه على مهنتي انه اعرض البيوت طبعا
انا بستاذن اي بيت بستاذن انه بتسمح لي
اعرض بيتك على السوشيال ميديا كتير ناس عم
تتقبل هذه الفكره حاولت دخل هيدي الفرحه
على مهنتي وحسيت حالي اني عم حقق هذا
الحلم
[موسيقى]